- C'est le début de l'été
en Afrique du Sud. Au Cap, on se
préparait ururururururururururue
désastreuse. Mais la suspension
des vols à destination de
l'Afrique australe a subitement
vidé les terrasses, les quais et
mamamamamamamamamamamamamamamame
chose", dit cette commerçante,
surtout qudédédécembre, en plus
des touristes, les Sud-Africains
qui vivent à l'étranger
pour Noël.
Le président sud-africain
ncncnce à nouveau
ces restrictions,
qu'il juge extrêmement dures,
et contre-productives.
Un concert d'indignations s'est
fait entendre des quatre coins
- And it is not only unfair,
but it is alsoésésésésésésésésés
dénoncent l'impact désastreuxdes
économies et sur leurs capacités
à lutter contre la contagion.
ces interdictions d'apartheid
des voyages.
- Allow me to say "travel
apartheid", which I think
is unacceptable. They are not
only deeply unfair and
- Inefficace, dit-il, parce
que les varintntntntnt pas
frontières et que l'Omicron
est déjà présent dans 28 pays
Alors pourquoi cibler
quelques pays en Afrique?
Injuste aussi, car l'Omicron
av p p p p p p p p p p p p p p t
d'être formellement identifié
en Afrique du Sud.-i-i-i-i-i-i-c
CHU de Québec-Université Laval
- Çêêêêême aller jusqu'à
des effets délétères : il y a
des pays qui peuvent maintenant
cas d'Omicron pour ne pas être
mis sur la liste rouge
des voyages.riririririririririre
l'Afrique du Sud; c'est un des
dedededede l'OMS qui surveillent
les variants en Afrique.
- L'interdiction de voyager
quand même beaucoup d'impacts
négatifs. Juste là, le f
d'avoir bloqué des avions, déjà,
en Afrique du Sud, on commence
à avovivivivivivivivivivivivivil
médical.
teteteteteteur Longtin rappelle
qu'en Afrique, la pauvreté
est à l'origine de maladies,
mortelles que la COVID.
- Pendant qu'on met
les restrictions et qu'en fait,
ces pays souvent vivucucucucucup
du tourisme, là, évidemment,
eteteteteteté explose.
il n'y a pas de PCU ou d'autres
programmes de filet social.
Donc ici, on parle d'arrêt
dans les programmes de lutte
aux autres m'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'.
Il y a des enfants qui vontmamae
de leur scolarité suite à ça.
Et d'autre problèmes colaté
qui est faite aux femmes
dans p p p p p p pays est
en explosion.
- Amnistie internationaleececece
explosion des cas de violence
conjugale depuis 18 mois, en
Ici Sophi M M M M M M M M M M a